juste pour revenir là-dessus parce que
moi je voudrais saluer et je le dis en
tout cas pour l'instant la loyauté de
Raquel Garrido Alexis Corbières et
Jean-Luc Mélenchon ils se disent c'est
un gars de chez nous face à un mec qui
est plutôt notre pote donc comment on
fait on est un peu dans la merde c'est
comme voilà c'est comme ça que ton père
et ta mère
a dit des choses extrêmement graves oui
c'est vrai ça donc ça peut pas garder
une position
on peut dire ce qu'a dit ils peuvent
dire Mélenchon garrideau Corbières
peuvent dire les propos tenus par Boyard
était aussi inacceptables il est faux
d'après notre expérience que Hanouna
promeut le racisme ou les idées
d'extrêmement il y avait un service
minimum à faire c'est neutralité est une
forme de compliqué pour ne rien dire
c'est ne pas le soutenir quelque part je
suis pas d'accord avec Eric parce que
leur silence c'est quand même lourd de
sens leur silence ça vaut désapprobation
pour Louis Boyard pour moi tout
simplement gêner exactement et moi je
voulais dire je trouve que c'est voilà
c'est c'est faire plaire après voilà ce
que je voulais dire aussi par rapport au
journaliste c'est que moi quand même
j'ai été choqué ce week-end par des
questions de journalistes qui ont
totalement éditorialisé BFM TV
c'est le fils de Patrice Duhamel qui
était patron de France Télévisions il
m'a demandé de me prendre son fils en
stage à l'époque je l'avais mis dans le
groupe etc après c'est Marc-Olivier
Fogiel qui l'a pris à BFM puisqu'il
connaît très bien son père voilà qu'il a
fait travailler également à France
Télévisions voilà donc lui lui aussi
c'est encore un gars qui crache dans la
soupe et il y en a un autre donc je
parlerai demain c'est Bertrand Chameroy
qui a fait une chroniqueuse qui a dit il
faut que l'arcom arrête voilà ce
saisissent de l'affaire et et facilement
et vraiment réveillez-vous l'arcom il
faut arrêter il faut arrêter que ça se
passe ça dans
tpmps avant de venir dans l'émission qui
nous a planté des milliers de fois et
encore je pourrais d'autres choses sur
lui voilà mais je le raconterai s'il
continue
Bertrand Chameroy qui fait bien le malin
et quand il voit il se chie dessus
c'est un peu comme tout le monde c'est
ça le problème